[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to your
in review now it's fair to say that few
of us will remember
2020 with much affection but there was a
lot of news worth looking back on
analyzing and where we can gently
mocking we'll also look ahead to what
could await us in 2021
be it the economic outlook or just the
ability to go to the pub without having
to worry about scotch eggs
so do stay with us for the next hour as
we're joined by the editor at large for
politics dot co dot uk
ian dunt the economics correspondent for
the spectator
kate andrews also the observers chief
leader writer sonia soder and the chief
executive of conservative
home mark wallace thank you all very
much for joining us in we're going to
start with
you there's no getting around it the
covert 19 pandemic has really dominated
the news this year so we've asked each
guest to choose one aspect of the story
that stood out
for them what was that aspect as far as
you were concerned
the government's complete inability to
handle it um i mean covert is basically
like
uh looking at the light from a distant
star right so from the moment you
actually have to impose a policy
you're dealing with events that took
place a month ago people take about two
weeks to get seriously sick once they
have it they're usually in hospital for
about two weeks before they die if
indeed that's what happens
so we were looking at events the origins
of which had already happened and if you
look at government policy throughout the
last
year it was this entirely reactive
process of dealing with things two weeks
too late three weeks too late four weeks
too late
they were too late on the first lockdown
they were too late really
in bringing in the tears trying to
explain to people how things were going
to function
after the lockdown they were told that
the tiers were ineffective
they continued with them anyway they
were too late for the second lockdown
they're now making the same sort of
mistakes over christmas
in the background of all of that you
have track and trace which we were
promised in this kind of
tub thumping jingoistic way would be
this british success story and in fact
it's just this mess of
privatized subcontracted ineffective
programming
throughout that what you have seen is
tens of thousands of deaths of people
that did not need to take place if the
government
was on top of what it was doing it was
late
late late every step of the way and it
is a degree of government failure which
we simply haven't seen in our lifetime
okay uh full marks are bringing in a
star so early uh
on this program uh kate do you think
it's a fair assessment i mean
none of us knew what this pandemic was
going to bring lots of different
countries handled it in lots of
different ways
why was the british way of handling it
wrong
well look i think a lot of mistakes have
been made along the way and am
has pointed a fair few of them out i'm
not as convinced that having locked down
days a week earlier would have
necessarily resulted in as
in as many lives saved as ann and i both
hope
would do i think what we've seen the
data from circuit breakers and whales
from
lockdowns in england especially the
second time around was suggested the
infection
rate goes up and down not always
necessarily when you want it to
a whale circuit breaker more or less
seems to be a failure now in getting
infections under control so i don't
think it's
as straightforward as that but england
in particular
the uk as a whole has a lot to answer
for when it comes to that number of
excess deaths in the first
wave of coronavirus that was indeed the
worst in europe uh that is a painful
track record and and one that you can
tell through
decisions that have been made more
recently the government really wants to
correct
mark you're a conservative supporter uh
editor of uh conservative
home your issue with with how it's been
handled is one particular element it's
the messaging
well i think as ian and kate just said
there's lots of different issues but one
thing that particularly
struck me was that once you had that
decision to lock down you had that
incredibly clear message the stay home
protect the nhs save lives you had the
deployment of
um the massive popularity of the nhs in
the messaging
you even had the queen coming on tv to
to help get the message across
and there's quite a lot of evidence say
that message had
um a huge cut through much more than any
other
government information message that i
can think of in recent years
but what was quite striking and shocking
was that after that
the the whole thing seemed to come off
the rails in terms of communication if
you're talking about
you know the rules and the official
policy are one thing but
communicating what you're doing how
people should react to it what happens
next
and how we're going to continue dealing
with something that's not for a matter
of weeks but months
and you know even flowing into 2021
communication is really really important
and what seemed to happen was that
people didn't get the
people including the press didn't get
the really clear
early signs of exactly how what the
route was going to be of
through this how the rules were going to
change in time and once they did start
changing they weren't always as clear as
they
should have been and and again you end
up now at the end of the tail end of the
year
um because the the idea was set out very
early on the rules will specify
every single thing about what you ought
to do the government has made a rod for
its own back and therefore every time
they come up with any set of rules
people then come back and say well
exactly how how big should the scotch
egg be in order to be able to
uh sit down and have a drink with it but
you know that that is something that's a
product of comms that went wrong and
when
if you consider how big the
communication pr state is and how
expensive it is
it's quite shocking that that that that
happened let's bring sonja in on this i
mean i mean sonia you know we think back
to big government campaigns road safety
campaigns you know clunk click for every
trick dig for victory
uh these are all things that that really
stick in the head don't they hands knees
face it immediately went viral you know
hands knee shoulders heads and toes
hands knees bumps are daisy
what was the government getting wrong
well i agree with mark i think
simplicity of messaging
is really really important but the other
thing that's so
important when you're looking to
communicate very important public health
messages
is engendering a sense of you know we're
all doing this together this is for the
common good
and i think the government really got
that right with its first set of
messaging it was like we've all got to
do this together we've all got to stay
home
to protect the nhs and to save lives so
that was quite effective at triggering
this idea that we're not just
staying home to keep ourselves safe
we're staying home to keep the people
safe you have to go out to work every
day you
can't stay at home because the jobs that
they've got
keeping the economy and the health care
system running
i think though that very quickly that
did start to break down
and the government moved to instead to
sort of suggest that actually there was
you know
the individuals were to blame when
things went wrong
um you know they would point to uh
pictures
of people uh congregating or breaking
the rules etc whereas actually we know
that the public
during the first lockdown really stuck
to it and they really did stick to the
ball so i think this idea that
oh it's all young people's fault for um
doing this or it's another grease fault
for doing that
that is actually really corrosive to
getting people
uh to um to sort of comply with public
health messaging because it's got to
come from a good place it's got to be
about what we're all doing
you know for each other rather than this
idea that sort of like you're laying the
path for blaming groups of individuals
and i think actually there's
quite a contrast between the way boris
johnson has handled this and nicholas
sturgeon as a communicator because
nicholas sturgeon has
much more rather than sort of focus on
groups that might be to blame or
focusing on the sticks
she's focused much more on the idea that
this is a collective social
responsibility and we're all in it
together and
in terms of the response you wanted to
jump out with the westminster bubble a
little bit didn't you and look at
inequality and what covert has
highlighted
that's right so i think one of the big
things this pandemic has sort of lifted
the corner of the carpet back on is the
massive structural inequalities that
afflict us in society
and i think that's true at a very basic
level on a health level so during the
first lockdown
people in white collar professional jobs
it's much easier for you to stay at home
and keep yourself safe than if you're in
low paid essential work if you're
collecting the bins for example if
you're a hospital porter
so i think it you know the pandemic
really revealed big
class-based inequalities in your ability
to keep yourself safe
i think as we experience the economic
impacts more and more and more and more
people tragically lose their jobs
we're going to hear much much more about
the inadequacy of unemployment benefit
you know families who never expected to
be living on unemployment benefit
parents losing their jobs as a result of
this pandemic they're going to find that
after 10 years of cuts to
tax credits and benefits it really isn't
very much money at all and then a couple
of other
sorts of inequality that i would mention
first of all educational inequality
um we know that the gap between children
from richer
and poorer backgrounds is has got a lot
bigger as a result of all that time
children had off school
the government just didn't do enough to
ensure that children from poorer homes
from disadvantaged homes
were getting learning opportunities
um you know over the summer holidays for
example to help them catch up
and then lastly gender inequality again
we know from surveys
uh that it's very much women who have
picked up the brunt of
the domestic work of child care uh
you know looking after the kids while
you're trying to work from home of the
emotional labor of making sure that
everyone's okay and that's going to have
real and long-lasting
impact on women's roles in the workplace
mark i mean
it is also fair to sort of look at the
population and say we didn't all of us
didn't exactly cover ourselves in glory
did we i mean
all of the panic buying and supermarkets
the stockpiling
what does that tell us about society
well to a certain extent you know these
things are natural they might not be
desirable and nobody really wants to be
uh to see anybody fighting each other
for toilet roll
um but to a certain extent these are
things that happen in a crisis
the fact is that you can look back and
see the way in which
news of a supposed tolerable shortage
that now seems never really existed
spread around the world through
different media platforms through social
media through rumors and so on
people will react to a crisis in in in
very deep seated ways which are
much older than any of the kind of media
or
or government systems we're talking
about but there is a responsibility of
course to
to work out how to address it it's it's
weird i think that
one thing we've seen in this is that at
times it's felt like politicians have
placed too much weight on
sometimes untested kind of behavioral
science those call of skepticism from
epidemiologists about
the idea that people were going to tire
or lock down quickly
um or lock down compliance quickly but
at other times
you can foresee things like stockpiling
and it seems like that
things like that haven't been given the
proper weight in terms of planning ahead
as to how people are going to react to
things whether you like it or not
let's bring in kate because it's the
economic impact that you're really
fascinated with and it does seem like
the government managed to find its magic
money tree um
and rishi sunai was keen to spend it and
spend it and spend it
once that's been found what's the
economic impact of us not
not really being able to ever unsee that
magic money tree again
well that's a very good question and i
think everybody's wondering when its
branches might start
falling off but for now it continues to
grow in the bank of england and this
conservative government
is by no means going to stop spending
that money now i think economists on the
left
and the right would agree that if
there's any time to spend a heck of a
lot of money on a one-off spending spree
it is
during a pandemic but what i've been
most fascinated by
is the fact that the government keeps
telling us that lockdowns are a matter
of trade-offs and they take these
trade-offs very seriously especially as
they relate to the economic impact
and also the non-covet health impact and
yet
in action they seem to hold those things
as being very secondary
uh to the immediate covert crisis and i
was most shocked
that it turned out in november that the
treasury had not bothered to model the
econom the economic impact
of the tier restrictions or specific
lockdown restrictions
so from the 10 pm curfew to crackdowns
on socializing
they hadn't tried to model the economic
impact of that now models are difficult
uh they're often wrong we've seen that
often as we try to model the virus
trajectory itself but at least it's
something government can give you that
you can hold to account
and you can ask questions and you can
dissect and boris johnson promised to
release his assessment of the tier
system
the social and economic and health
impact of that and when we actually read
it
a few weeks back it turned out to be a
justification as to why the government
wasn't going to give us any data
the time says there is a secret dossier
that reveals the economic impact but
it's not something
that they're sharing with the public
anyone who's been under these lockdown
restrictions knows full well what that's
doing to their community
to local business the hospitality sector
in particular is under so much strain at
the moment
and i just find it quite unbelievable
really that you know you can make the
argument for lockdown and you can make
it wholeheartedly but
you would expect if they're really
talking about trade-offs that they would
have assessed some of the other things
and the medium to long-term health
impacts on people from a struggling
economy
and from many patients not being able to
access care i just don't think from
government we've seen anywhere
near enough of the actual breakdown of
these trade-offs and what they mean for
the public
okay a lot of negatives there about
covert thank you all very much
for bringing those uh but also some
positives let's not forget clap for care
as let's
forget all of us using dignitational
technology a lot more and all of us
looking out for our neighbors
well after the break other choices for
big stories that got us talking this
year
so stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to our year in review we
turn now to our panelists choices
for what would have been their big story
of the uh if it wasn't for that pesky
pandemic
uh let's start with kate now we promised
we didn't just book you because you are
an american but it is certainly helpful
um from covert from the election black
lives matter
what is going on in america what an
extraordinary year
it has been and the u.s presidential
election and the lead-up to it would
have certainly been my story had it not
been for the covet crisis
because it's not a straightforward
narrative the terrible killing of
george floyd in may uh really blew the
lid off the pressure cooker that is race
relations in america and have been
building for some time
i mean here in the states uh hearing i
can't breathe on camera as a black man
is killed
it's not even the first time we've heard
that eric gardner six years previously
was
put in a chokehold by police and killed
on the street for selling
single cigarettes so it was a long time
coming and americans have shown that
they really want to tackle this but
interestingly
not through identity politics the
radical left in america was defeated in
the primary process for the democrats
and
emerged the the most centrist uh career
politician you could really get in joe
biden and he won
the presidential election in an
electoral landslide he had the most
votes cast for
him than any other presidential
candidate in history but again
interestingly donald trump had the
second
highest number of votes cast for him and
it's not so simple
as to say the democratic party dominated
we have seen the republican party do
very well
on the state level and it looks like
they may keep the senate
you have had the u.s president donald
trump doing everything that he can
to undermine the process but i don't
think the american people are falling
for it american institutions have held
up and been incredibly robust uh from
the election itself to the courts
uh so i think you see to be a little bit
optimistic in america that's hopefully
going to find purpose and and
unification once again and can start to
tackle some of these very difficult
issues that have all been exposed this
year
and ian let's bring you in i mean do you
think they're going to have to wheel
president trump out from behind his desk
and how much are we all going to miss
melania and that
rictus grin um if you found anyone
that's going to miss melania's richter
screen
i think you really need to check up on
their their emotional health because
that is not something that any of us are
going to be missing
no they are obviously going to have to
pry him out of there but let's be clear
like i mean
just like kate said they were not
trounced
donald trump sort of revealed that this
kind of politics
really brutal very very reactionary
nationalist right-wing identity politics
works it didn't win him the election but
it absolutely was not comprehensively
rejected by voters
his now attempt to try and say well look
there's a big conspiracy against me
um there's been electoral fraud
everywhere
several very very senior people in the
republican party are not distancing
themselves from that in fact most of the
senior republicans you see are anonymous
when they start to distance themselves
from it so you're seeing quite a
dangerous process happen in the
background which is the republican party
move away from accepting the legitimacy
of democratic results
so democrats got in it is a good result
for anyone that considers them even
vaguely saying in politics
but in the background there is a really
disturbing drumbeat that has been
perpetuated
by trump and that was not rejected by
american voters
okay we talked a little bit about
trump's stubbornness another personal
stuff and this is something that you
wanted to bring in
sonia and this is brexit and boris
johnson yes absolutely and
obviously american election was a huge
story but i think here in the uk if it
weren't for the pandemic it would have
been brexit that story that has just
been ticking along continuously
since you know the last five six years
in this country and i think the thing
that
really stands out for me is here we are
we're literally on the cusp of being
about to leave the
single market and the customs union the
transition period
at the end of this year and so many
features of the debate are exactly the
same exactly the same debate we were
having back in 2016 and boris johnson is
still saying
the same things to us that he was back
then which is this idea that there just
isn't this very painful
trade-off at the heart of brexit which
of course there is
and um you know brexit for boris johnson
and the people on the leave campaign
was always about taking back control and
national sovereignty
but what they never fronted up with us
what they never told us
was that you know you can you we can
theoretically have an absolute a clean
break from the eu we can lead the single
market in customs union
but there are huge implications the good
friday agreement and arrangements on the
island of ireland because the good
friday agreement was always predicated
on the uk being part of a single market
and customs union
and there are also massive implications
for trade because you can't have a clean
break and say
we absolutely you know we don't sign up
to any form of regulatory alignment with
the eu
but then still accept harry free access
to the
um single market in europe and that has
huge implications for uh british
exporters so we was we're still being
told at the end of this year
you know we can leave and we can trade
on you know we can have a sort of
a hard brexit note a free trade deal or
we could have
a a no deal brexit and it all be okay
britain's still gonna do
wonderfully um on the world stage it's
gonna do brilliantly economically
but really that is it that level of
dishonesty is still there
brexit contained quite a painful
trade-off
and if you want to take back control if
you want to
um not regulatory align with the rest of
the eu then you have to accept
tariffs and this idea that we can ever
do a trade deal with
any massive economy or trading block and
not have some compromise
on common standards around regulations
around what you know workplaces labor
market
environmental standards for example it's
for the birds okay there is no such
thing as national sovereignty in the
19th century
world which is what we're arguing for
and we should just point out that as
we're recording this uh
still no decision still going to the
wire we were hoping we would get a
decision before we started you know we
had a word with boris but
it wasn't possible um mark to you to
react to that there is a delicious irony
isn't there in the man standing in front
of that bus
talking about the money for the nhs
being the one that has to get it over
the line
well there is there is some irony to
that in many ways it's unfortunate and i
think part of the source of some of the
problems
that we saw back um after the referendum
through the 2017 general election
was that due to obviously the the way
that leadership election
turned out within the conservative party
you ended up without the people
who campaigned for leave running the
government that was
at that time was trying to implement
brexit i agree with
sonia on one thing that she's just said
which is had it not been for
covid and the pandemic the really big
story this year
would have been brexit but i disagree
with her on the reason why the fact is
that
after several very ignominious very
damaging
years for westminster in terms of sheer
indecision the
the real difficulty that the political
class in terms of politicians
had implementing and adapting to that
result
um actually finally at long last in 2020
boris johnson having won the election on
the slogan of get brexit done
has got brexit done i think it's very
easy if you
you know people don't have to agree with
brexit but i think it'd be a mistake
to underestimate how important that is
to a huge number of people around the
country
who for a very long time had felt that
frankly politicians of all parties
hadn't listened to them people in power
didn't pay attention to what they wanted
in that referendum they voted a way in
which
you know almost all the the top
politicians including the prime minister
and the chancellor
uh barack obama and others didn't want
them to
and then they visibly saw westminster
struggle to accept
the willingness to keep its promise to
them to do what the people chose
finally in 2020 thank goodness people
have seen the most powerful people in
the land
do the thing that voters told them to do
that's extremely important and i think
had it not happened had brexit been
thwarted as various people
wanted over that period of several years
i think
we'd see a huge amount of very serious
damage done
to faith in our institutions our
processes and our democracy
and thank goodness we've avoided that
okay in what do you think about that i
mean do you think that as we stand here
the prime minister has got brexit done
has his oven ready deal pinged
no i find it quite amusing to say like
well you know finally there was a prime
minister that got brexit done when it's
like but it's been 12 months now
we're still talking about it i can
guarantee you now that when this program
goes out the end of
next year we will be talking about it
again over the months to come and it
won't be at the very beginning of
january and this is regardless of
whether there's a deal or no deal it'll
probably be towards you know the middle
of january and going on for the first
quarter of next year
we're going to see some very chaotic
scenes on the border especially between
dover calais we're going to see
all the old bureaucratic requirements
that are demanded all over the world
suddenly come back to the continent so
let me assure you when people say
he's going to get brexit done he has got
brexit done he hasn't so far
you're going to be seeing a lot of
brexit news some extremely shambolic
chaotic ugly brexit news filling up the
air time in the early part of next year
as well
joy we all love talking about it so much
don't we us journalists are not bored
at all in your choice this this section
and now now this is the man who was
apparently the inspiration for mr darcy
in bridget jones diary
um kierstahler how has he performed
apparently not though i was always in
love with that story but she's come out
and said that it wasn't him after all
and he's tried to i mean you could see
kia starve he was on the radio the other
day tried to conceal his disappointment
at this fact and i don't think doing a
particularly good job of it
and what's going on in labor is quite
significant and it's not just
significant for the fate of labor or the
fate of the sort of progressive left
it's really significant for two key
reasons the first one is if this country
is going to function
on a democratic level it needs a
opposition
that actually poses some sort of threat
to the government and we haven't seen
that since
once jeremy corbyn was leader and the
end result was that the conservatives
just
became more and more extreme
predominantly on brexit but on other
issues
it is no way to have a country i had
friends you know the last election
obviously and this is regardless of
whether your left or right remain or
leave
they would passionately oppose the
government and yet they couldn't vote
for the opposition even wherein that
seat the opposition was most likely to
win
and the reason for that was
fundamentally moral and that comes down
to the second
reason that this is crucial which is
that labor
was allowed to get sucked into the mud
on anti-semitism to the point where
liberal
left-wing people simply could not lend
it in support without feeling that they
were giving their sort of
tacit consent towards that proposition
now that is a situation that we just
haven't
seen in this country in our lifetime it
was a level
of moral disaster that was unthinkable
years before it happened
starmar has started the process this
year of cleaning the party up
but already and really the crucial
moment came
when jeremy corbyn put out a statement
on the day that the report came out on
anti-semitism
basically doing all the things he had
done until that stage because that was
the moment that you couldn't keep
the corbyn people on board while dealing
with anti-semitism in the labour party
and that set up a battle
that dominated the second half of this
year and that is going to play out into
next year
it is a battle that you cannot stress
the importance of
enough on the basis of not making sure
that one of the main
parties in britain is not a racist party
that is an absolutely crucial battle
is it crucial this year and it'll be
crucial for the next it is indeed
right i think we'll take a short pause
there but do join us after the break as
our panel
share their heroes and villains of 2020
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to our 2020 urine
review here on sky news
if you're just joining us we're looking
back over the highs and lows of 2020
with
our four guests the editor at large for
politics dot co dot uk ian dunt
the economics correspondent for the
spectator kate andrews the observers
chief leader writer
sonia soder and the chief executive of
conservative home
mark wallace now in this section we're
going to be
looking at heroes and villains the lack
of the panto season
isn't going to stop us from doling out
those festive cheers and jeers
oh no it isn't we'll start with our
panel's heroes and it's sonia first of
all
you've picked the man that many says
should be running the country tell us
about him
so i've picked marcus rashford the 23
year old manchester united footballer
who forced not
one but two u-turns from the government
on the provision of free school lunches
for children from poor backgrounds
during the summer holidays during a
pandemic i think there were just
a couple of things that really make
marcus rashford stand out first of all
even though he's this world famous
footballer this was always about the
issue for him it was never about his own
ego that's so
clear from the way he talked about the
issue he wasn't afraid to speak truth to
power
even when the government gave him an mbe
that didn't buy him off he still kept
campaigning for what he believed was
right
and secondly i think the thing that's so
brilliant about him is that he grew up
in poverty himself
free school meals made a big difference
to him and he spoke
so articulately about the difference
that this sort of government support can
make to you and
look how where he's ended up so i think
he's really helped
change the way that the public see
poverty
and the challenge of making sure that
your kids get
food on the table when you're in a very
very low paid job and the difference
that that can make to their lives so
okay kudos to him marcus rashford number
one of our heroes
ian who have you gone for i've come for
nhs staff
special mentions captain tom there who
are on the front line during this thing
when most of us you know in jobs frankly
like the ones that most of you are
contributors to this program have we're
all safely at home they were still going
out to work doing the job in the middle
of this pandemic
and it's not just really nhs staff what
was important this year was seeing
how many people there are on the real
front line of keeping society running
and that's the people that we don't
usually recognize right so yes teachers
also people that come to deliver parcels
to your door people that work in the
corner shop that work in the supermarket
who don't really get any acknowledgement
yet most of the time in society we think
well we're going to pay the guy that
works in marketing a lot
none of us would have noticed if
marketing had ceased to function this
year
we would have very much noticed if the
guys that worked in supermarkets weren't
doing it and yet they're not paid well
enough
they're not very given very good
conditions and if anything good was to
come from what we've gone through we're
starting to recognize the kind of value
that they bring to the world that we
live in
be interesting to see uh how much we
remember of that in the years to come
won't it
uh kate technically your hero uh came to
the world's attention
last year uh but without them we might
not have been prepared
for this year who yes
i've selected dr lee wen liang and he is
the chinese doctor who
literally alerted his colleagues at the
end of december last year to an illness
that he thought
looked like sars but i've picked him in
2020 because sadly he passed away from
kova 19
in february but in mere months had a
huge impact
on the world he was a member of the
communist party of china but he blew the
whistle anyway
he was hauled in intimidated forced to
sign a piece of paper saying he was
essentially making it up
he himself very sadly died of this virus
because he continued
to help the patients that needed him
most and we'll never know the
counterfactual if
we had been alerted to this virus sooner
if it could have been better contained
and a fewer people would have died but
i feel certain saying that dr lee hath
has probably saved countless lives
with his bravery by by in a very
difficult situation
with an authority authoritarian state
breathing down his neck
uh still blowing that whistle alerting
his colleagues and alerting the world at
large
and mark you've also stayed with with a
covered linked
hero well two heroes who are very very
humble but they too their actions could
save many many lives
yes my nominations for dr uga sahin and
dr ozlem turitzi the couple who
are behind the cutting edge technology
which has produced the first
vaccine to be approved and to be
delivered to people the fact is that
back in march april may a lot of people
were talking about the fact that it may
take years to get a vaccine maybe a
vaccine might never
be possible to think then that by the
end of this year
a vaccine would already be coursing
through the veins of
well over 100 000 people in this country
it's being transported around the world
it's getting approval in all sorts of
different countries
that is an amazing testament to human
ingenuity
to science to the capacity of people to
find
um a a way to counter a scourge like
over 19. i think it's remarkable made a
huge difference to
all of humanity that in such a quick
time they've come riding to the rescue
so an extra chair for all of those
people will even send them a very small
glass
extra glass of sweet sherry so they can
celebrate
their fantastic achievements uh what
about the villains though who's getting
extra servings of sprouts
sonja you first my villain is uh pretty
patel the home secretary who has really
been at the forefront of the
government's culture wars fights they've
tried to pick with
um asylum seekers with anti-racist
protesters
in order to distract from what's going
wrong with brexit and the pandemic
in particular she has really attacked
the legal profession
lawyers who are doing their jobs we have
this thing called the rule of law in the
uk
uh which means that you're entitled to a
lawyer to legal representation no matter
who you
are and pretty patel has attacked
lawyers for doing that job
to the extent that she's been criticized
heavily by the lord chief justice for
undermining the rule of law so
um i think she really deserves this
award this year
you do wonder what would be in her
secret santa uh gift this year don't you
uh ian who have you picked as your
villain dominic cummings who even looks
like a villain from some sort of
straight to betamax
tourism and barnard castle though he has
well you know there are advantages to
almost everything i've never even read
i'm going to admit it i've never even
heard of barnard castle until he went
there
um but now apparently it's doing very
well look there's two reasons for it i
mean the first one is the barnard castle
trip which you know took this moment of
sort of national solidarity i think
there was quite a lot of pent-up
national solidarity left over from the
brexit divisions
that just really emerged in the first
half of the year and that
turned into one rule for them another
rule for us as soon as bernard castle
happened you can't
repair what he did in terms of public
trust
the second was this kind of pound shot
shakespearean tragedy that his career
involved
he spent years writing these long
lengthy interminable blogs about how the
world would all be better if he ran it
finally he gets it he wins his
referendum get an 80-seat majority for
the tories he can do whatever he wants
and what does he do
he just complains at people you know for
a few months
and then resigns you just think you
could have done anything like you could
have done anything at that point from
whatever it was you actually wanted to
do in the world
and it turned out in the end after all
that bile all that noise
there was nothing there was just nothing
to it mark 10 second reaction to that i
mean dominic cummings did do a lot for
misfits and weirdos didn't he
i've got to say barnard castle is a
fantastic place you should definitely
visit here once the rules
of castle as a northerner please
exactly um yeah the the fact is that
downing street
is a machine that eats people up one
once they once they go into it um
i wrote back in the summer and took a
lot of flack of writings at the time
that frankly
once that issue of the rules uh had come
up there
he ought to have gone then unfortunately
by the end
by the end of the year the government's
taking a lot of the pain for keeping him
and lost him as it is so but that's
obviously you know an even worse outcome
for them okay
kate now in theory one might have
expected your choice to be up there
among the heroes
but they're your villains why uh so i
asked
when i mentioned dr lee what could have
happened if we knew about this virus
earlier and if we had
committed to tackling it especially
those who actually paid to do so and i
don't think there's a bigger culprit on
this front than the world
health organization uh their director
general was saying
as late as february that there was not
widespread community transition from
this
virus there has been mass praise for
china it's actually been called
transparent by the world health
organization
amazingly so and they've put very
strange political connections above
actually keeping people safe this is an
organization get that gets 3.8 billion
dollars a year and is there to keep us
safe in the midst of a pandemic and
i think it has utterly failed to do so
so maybe this christmas it should have a
maybe a bit of a slash or a cut to its
funding or we should at least consider
what that money is really going towards
well thanks very much for that kate now
mark your uh villain
is somebody who probably would have been
a hero in a previous year this year
distinguished himself through
bad hair dye and a press conference in
the garden center
yes among other demerits you know my
nomination is rudy giuliani and
by extension the wider trump legal team
we've touched on this a little bit
earlier but
there's a difference between doing the
the many things that
uh trump did wrong in the presidency and
then
after you've lost the election mounting
a very public campaign to effectively
try to
embed conspiracy theory to delegitimize
the american election process
to delegitimize uh fundamental u.s
institutions which are important not to
just to america but to the whole world
we need a healthy democratic uh strong
united states and um i've got to say
rudy giuliani having trashed his own
reputation
has now effectively done to the part of
the republican party what ian was
talking about jeremy corbyn having done
to labor
uh earlier on he's embedded this
paranoia mindset and done a huge amount
to try to fuel
the idea that election simply isn't
legitimate and unfortunately
just like labour's problems that's going
to be a generational problem to try and
work out from within american politics i
fear
okay so those are our villains and our
heroes of 2020 when we come back we'll
look ahead to what could be in store
for 2021 do stay with us
welcome back to the final part of our
year in review now there's no denying
that 2020 has been the toughest year
that many of us can remember but 2021's
news agenda will it cure our pandemic
fatigue
uh let's ask our panel for their
predictions um
mystic mark it's time to look into your
crystal ball as the mists clear what do
you see for 2021's economy
well the economy is going to be the
crucial question the one of the
many depressing aspects of the pandemic
is that even when we come out of all of
this what will be emerging is a uk and a
world
which is in some ways tattered and faded
simply because so much has been put on
hold so many jobs have been
destroyed so many things have been
paused and
the huge question is going to be how
that economic fight back
begins and how it continues and kate's
staying
on the economy you're concerned about
people getting out there into the wider
world getting back to normal and how
quickly that's going to take
yeah there are a lot of outstanding
questions especially around vaccine
rollout and how long that takes that
will be a major
determining factor as to when we can
loosen restrictions but
my major question is when we do how easy
is it going to be
to restore people's freedoms to them the
rosier side of this year is that we all
did look out for our neighbors even
people we've never met before because we
didn't want to pass on the virus to them
but
i i think the darker side of this year
is the rise of the coveted snitches
uh this idea of coven marshals that a
conservative government
whipped up in policing one another as
well as ourselves i don't think there
has been enough focus on
the huge encroachment on our civil
liberties that has taken place and
i worry that it is going to be slightly
harder to return people's freedoms to
them
when it is fully safe to do so thank
goodness we
have this vaccine if we hadn't we would
have had to learn to live with the virus
because
it is very human to want to socialize to
want to meet new people to want to be
close and
you cannot crack down on that forever i
think the british public have been
incredible this year broadly adhering to
the rules for as long
as they have but there have to be
solutions that now looks like it's going
to be a vaccine
but still once we have that roll out of
the vaccine uh you know we we need to be
very very clear that all of these
liberties are coming back
no questions about it uh and and i think
there needs to be a real effort a real
push to make sure that people re-embrace
them
and sonia you're also thinking about
covert and and perhaps more of an
existential crisis that it might have
created for the coming year
my prediction would be that we're going
to continue to see support for scottish
independence grow
over the next year boris johnson isn't a
particularly popular figure in scotland
i think there is a lot of disaffection
in scotland as to the way that the
westminster government has handled the
pandemic
and you have seen support for scottish
independence growing the next year
next year is going to bring new
challenges as well as the pandemic we're
going to see brexit happen
scotland voted remain a lot of people
think that the increase that we've seen
in the support for scottish independence
has also got something to do with brexit
so my prediction would be that you are
going to see support for scottish
independence go up and i think
it's increasingly it's becoming
increasingly
likely that we will see another
referendum on scottish
independence in the next sort of five
years and i think that the
chances that that it it's won this time
by the snp
unfortunately for my perspective are
increasing
and what do you think about that mark i
mean boris johnson this year described
devolution
uh scotland as a disaster did he really
put his foot in it he didn't do a lot of
favors
for scottish conservatives did he well i
think if you had uh
senior scottish conservatives on this
show you might get an answer that you
couldn't air on a family program like
this
but this is going to be the big question
the snp know what their plan of
plan of attack is going to be what
answer will unionism come up with
in scotland for the scottish voice for
the union making the case for the united
kingdom
but also frankly trying to get the some
of the debate back on to the snp's
government of scotland which leaves an
awful lot to be desired
staying with the north and staying with
politics
out of westminster the red wall ian that
is something you're
thinking about for the coming year are
voters
in that swathe of the north that that
turned conservative a year ago going to
feel a bit stuffed
this christmas by by boris johnson do
you think
they're starting to lose a bit of faith
i mean you're looking at the polling um
in quite granular detail it's no big
change yet but you're seeing reductions
in the midlands reductions in the north
in conservative party support reductions
in towns
reductions in rural areas and most of
that isn't going directly to labor it's
going into don't know
um in fact from the 2019 tory voters has
gone from one in ten to one in five and
now on don't know territory
so they're alienated from boris johnson
they don't think he's done a good job on
covid they're not impressed with the
government's
handling of brexit not whether to do
whether you think brexit should take
place
but how has the government managed it i
imagine that the people that feel that
way will
continue to feel that way and even more
strongly over the course of the next
year when we see the first practical
implications
but they're not there for the taking for
kyostama he has to prove that he can
earn their vote and for him to do that
and he does get this is he has to come
up with a form of
patriotic progressive politics a sense
of place
a sense that he actually loves the
country that he wants to run something
which
jeremy corbyn for unfathomable reasons
was unable to demonstrate
he gets it next year we find out whether
he can deliver on that
and that is going to prove crucial in
the years to come uh ian thanks very
much
for that and sonia what what do you
think i mean do you think kierstarma is
the man
who's going to be big enough strong
enough to hold boris johnson's feet to
the fire over the coming year
i do think so i think he's done pretty
well so far in holding boris johnson to
account i don't think he has the same
pizzazz or charisma say as tony blair
but i do think he's
a solid leader he's doing pretty well in
the polls considering he's only been
in in post for not that long so yes i
think he i think he will continue to do
well
and and we're going to ask you all who
you think is going to be leading the
country in a year's time you all
said boris johnson but i want to ask you
why
uh mark why do you think boris johnson
will still be prime minister
two reasons firstly he won that election
and that big majority and that does buy
you a lot of credit in in in politics
being being a winner the second reason
is that
the pandemic has been a once in a
century event
and and not unreasonably i think the
next question is what the government's
actually going to do in more normal
times in governing the uk
sonia why do you think boris johnson
will still be in charge
i think he's got a majority of 80 so i
think that makes him relatively
untouchable for at least the next couple
of years
and kate uh i have to agree with mark
especially when it comes to boris
johnson it's thought that he
won over many of those red wall seats
not necessarily the conservative party
so
he has a lot of good will from those new
mps who think that they came in
with boris johnson and of course he
doesn't want to be a pandemic prime
minister
he wants to focus much more on the
domestic policies he laid out in his
manifesto
and i highly doubt he'd go anywhere
before he had a stab at them
i mean i'm sure he's going to hope that
next year ian is a little bit more
hectic
for him than this year you know he's
been hospitalized near
death and had a new baby plus the the
big new job why do you think he'll still
be here in 12 months time
i mean look he's demonstrably unsuitable
as prime minister as his record over
this year
shows is catastrophic in ways that can
barely be described using human words
but nevertheless the vultures are only
starting to circle in the conservative
party they've been chatting away
you can see the beginning of that
classic tory process of let's stab our
leader to death it's what they do
and eventually they probably will get
there with him but we're still at the
beginning i would say in two three years
time
then let's have a conversation about
what the parliamentary party does to it
okay thank you all very much that is it
i'm afraid the crack has
all been pulled it's just the tidying up
uh that's to do
now thanks to our panel ian kate sonya
and mark thanks to all of you for giving
up your time today
we hope you've enjoyed our year in
review or at least that you can take
comfort
in being one hour a little bit closer to
the end of 2020.
thank you so much for joining us enjoy
the festive period as much
as you can and do take care bye
[Music]
you